ela sobe 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer um carro do controle remoto mas
não é que o controle modo por rádio que
é por fio e aí fiz esse projeto não é
tão simples que vocês consigam fazer sem
precisar comprar aqui os componentes
pela internet e essas coisas que vocês
vão estar basicamente de 2014 pode ser
um cara velho ou então dvds players como
eu vou usar em um cenário de baterias
daquelas de novo volte e o resto vocês
vão ter em casa se não tiverem vão poder
substituir por outras coisas
então vamos lá para fazer parceria do
carro e usar uma garrafa
mas se vocês quiserem podem usar outra
coisa qualquer um protesto é que vocês
façam um retângulo mais ou menos com
estas medidas aqui
ou seja eu vou usar só de comprimento ea
largura vai ser igual à da garrafa mas
deve ser mais ou menos em 15 cm e 4 de
maio
isa base usando tons de picolé mas se
vocês quiserem podem fazer usando o
cartão com vai com cartão seja um crime
muito resistente ok
adicionar dois plugins na parte traseira
do carro uma vez que vou fazer um corpo
que pode utilizar a estrutura então é
melhor deixar isto bem forte
e como eu tinha falado anteriormente
agora um cenário de tirar um produzindo
aqui tenho ser virado pois para encaixar
a folia e polia vai ser feito usando um
pessoal
por essa nem podia precisar de duas
moedas com tamanhos diferentes e vão ser
também um pedaço de cartão e aquele
cartão sim bem compensado com o aumento
vai nas caixas de cereais que não nos
nas caixas de bolachas e que vocês têm
encurtar mais ou menos como estou
fazendo aqui
mas vocês podem pôr mais camadas
quiseram forçar mais
para juntar as camadas de tule e vou
usar uma super cola para maneira que
está havendo aqui a inglaterra em
portugal também no brasil existe é o
super bons me engano simples diz é de
juntar as três partes é importante que
vocês passem as pecinhas por uma lixa
para ficar tudo assim luizinho para não
estragar depois use elásticos que vocês
não por nela vai precisar fazer um furo
no centro da polia para isso podem usar
uma faca afiada e foi aí que o cliente
peçam ajuda um adulto ou então podem
usar uma furadeira normal
o futuro tem que ter o mesmo dentro do
pub no churrasco vocês vão utilizar
pessoal extra agirem precisar de uma
caneta corta e cola e do modo que vocês
tenham a ver o vídeo
quando a escola oscar um saldo de duas
tampas faça um furo no centro e depois
prendam ao povo de churrasco vocês
tiverem atenção antes colocar a última
roda vocês têm que passar o eixo da roda
com você escolar ou seja o conflito pela
polícia e na política tem por dois ou um
elástico a que os pequeninos depois
fazerem isso podem encaixar o político
na última roda corta o tamanho certo e
cola
aprendam a polícia ao haiti usando uma
super cola para movimentar e da direção
do carro vamos usar de 2012
eu vou ter ao de dvds players mas se
vocês não tiverem podem usar outros
quaisquer sul o importante é que seja um
pouquinho
quando o motor que você estiver em modo
que os clubes fiquem alinhadas caso o
setor não tenha polia podem sempre fazer
uma aos tios daquela que vocês viram
anteriormente mas tem que ser mais
pequenina depois fazer a política é só
colar no motor e depois vão em aulas de
modo que seja possível
depois por lá o relógio faz uma abertura
no centro mas a mesma zona assinalada do
modo que essa abertura permita passar a
folia do outro motor que você estiver
cortou em pedaços de caneta é colar guru
geralmente superior à da base mas
somente um centro e depois corta um
pedaço ouvindo que coleco a mesma
largura
para finalizar sem coar a par do potinho
com a parte do planeta
em seguida tem colocar as rodas o
princípio é mais ou menos igual ao que
vocês viram anteriormente só que desta
vez não vai ter por dia faça os
orifícios nas tampas passa empate na
primeira etapa porém um cola esperem
séculos caro passando pela caneta e do
outro lado põe tanto nos têm que deixar
ligeiramente folgado
agora vamos desarticular o motor é
bastante simples é só passar a acolher
pelo orifício profissional encontra base
e pó não cola a volta quando oscar tem
claro é aquela base com rodas e
importante é que eu fico bem
centralizado que vocês começam aquilo
passa uma pintinha lá no maio e depois
cola na polia do motor número tutorial
tempo tocar aqui esta coisa porque a
parte da frente ficava mais alta do que
a parte de trás com juca e ficou mais ou
menos igual
e agora vou mostrar como eu fiz a parte
de cima do carrinho eu usei uma garrafa
de plástico e alguns pontinhos de picolé
a partida com poucos poderes picolé nos
treinos vocês vendo a imagem
vocês conseguem perceber facilmente como
eu fiz
depois realizado em design tem colocar
os cabos antes de colar ea cabine
eu vou usar um dos carros do filamento
único mas se vocês tiverem de quilos de
cobre em tenho vários filament são mais
maleáveis usem esses porque são muito
melhor
em seguida coloque a cabine mas o
documento que vocês ponham termo um
político virado para cima explica que
para enrolar o fio a volta de espírito e
evita que o fio sem rodas
o que a gente já está feito praticamente
se estudar os últimos retoques e depois
vou ensinar como fazer o comando
o comando é bastante simples vamos falar
basicamente alguns fios quatro baterias
uma garrafa e aquela parte da rolha que
vocês tiraram para fazer a caminho do
carro
uma coisa que eu vou fazer é tirar os
conectores de duas baterias de novos que
vão servir de conectores para outras
baterias de novo volte
o padre que os conecta o já tem fios um
dos pólos têm dois fios e outros têm só
um tabu era qual dos pólos têm 2 qual
tem um não faz diferença em caixa é
aquela partiram pra fazer é cabin lugar
assinalado no vídeo como os conectores
na parte de cima da garrafa mais ou
menos centralizado e ponham bastante
cola e digo isto porque um dos
conectores se desprendeu quando eu
estava a fazer o teste
não sei como fazer esta parte para ficar
um pouco confuso dos preços subir uma
vez que o chivas tente esmalte mas o que
acontece é que o pólo que tem só um fio
tem ficar numa e aqui um ponto em dois
filmes têm ficar do lado e vocês têm
desencapar as extremidades em controlar
algo mas somente como isto e prendam com
cola nas partes que vocês têm uma vez
para simbolizar um silvado fazer duas
aberturas em cada tampa e tem que
separar os 4.100 dois para cada lado e
os dois filhos têm que ser
correspondente ao mesmo torok o caminho
é para a frente para trás para a direita
e para a esquerda porque há uma variação
da popularidade seja inversa puridade
quando vocês ródão uma das tampas vocês
passam os fios pelas tampas e qual elas
com modo fica assim extremidades para
assim provado com suas antenas e vocês
quando surgiram um lado para o outro e
aí os contactos vão mudando ok o que é
positivo para o negativo que nunca tive
que passar todo positivo pois vocês
ajustam é de modo que os demais já está
ok vocês teste onde escolar por exemplo
quando o rock pra frente o tempo quero
vai pra frente quando eu noto contrato
só vai pra trás e depois a parte da
direcção esquerda direita também uma
coisa quando vir para a esquerda vai à
esquerda como à direita vai para a
direita
nossa gente se vocês cuidarem que vocês
testam para ver para que lado e foi
terminado comando é supor as pilhas está
pronto a usar uma coisa que aconteceu
comigo é que as rodas da frente não
girava no lugar para elas irem para a
direita ou então para a esquerda é
preciso dar um movimento para frente
então por trás mas você usar um motor
mais forte provavelmente elas vão gerar
no lugar
então esse foi só o cigarro sofia espero
que tenham gostado se você tiver alguma
sugestão de algum projeto que se chama
os comentários que vai ter que fazer
porque ele não tem nada fechado na
capital